[Musique]
une utopie parce qu'il ya un premier
cadre qui est suivie d'un pari 2050 un
pari vert ou le monde y est totalement
en symbiose avec son environnement la
société les humains et l'environnement
sont totalement en symbiose avec la
ville qui autorise autogénérés sur sa
propre énergie et de l'autre côté les ya
un petit peu plus dystopique où on est
dans un monde totalement numérisée
déshumanisée où le monde vit dans le
virtuel
c'est vraiment soutenir la vision des
taux d audit et de vision il y en a qui
est dans une vision qui dans notre
vision mais là quelle est la réelle
voilà ça c'est à nous de choisir me suis
basé sur qu'est sur des choses très
concrètes
je me suis donné sur les travaux de
vincent callebaut aucun architecte
français qu'a imaginé plusieurs versions
plusieurs villes dont paris 2050 vert
donc voilà j'ai voulu aurait cherché un
petit peu quelque chose qui serait
possible c'est ma vision à moi je dis
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait être qu'est ce
que comment pour être le monde de demain
et de façon dont j'imagine lequel on va
choisir c'est vraiment un objectif qui
était derrière c'est vraiment une
question à questionnement voulez vous
les posez un questionnement aux gens qui
vont venir